Rather than one person reading the entire ledger, say we
had more people to help, like the staff of your accounting
department. We'll split them into two groups, called the mappers and
the reducers. Then we'll take the ledger, break it into chunks,
give each chunk to one of the mappers. That way all
the mappers can work at the same time, each over a
small fraction of the data. Let's see what a mapper would
do. They will take the first record in their ledger, and
on an index card write the name of the store,
and the amount of a sale. Then they'll take the
next record, and repeat. As they're writing the index cards
they'll pile them up so that cards for the same
store go in the same pile. By the end, each
mapper will have a pile of card per store. Once
the mappers have finished, the reducers can collect their sets
of cards. We'll tell each reducer which store they're responsible for.
Such as this one for New York City, and this
one for Miami and Los Angeles. The reducers go to the
mappers and retrieve the pile of cards for their stores.
It's fast for them to do because the mappers have already
separated the cards into a pile per store. Once the
reducers have retrieved all their data, they collect all the small
piles and create a larger pile. Then they start going through
the piles one at a time. All they have to do
at this point is add up all the amounts from all the cards in
the pile. That gives them a total sales for that store. They can then write
that amount on their final sheet. To
keep things organized each reducer goes through his
or her set of piles in alphabetical
order. In other words, Los Angeles before Miami.